avec le froid en tout cas c'est la
grippe qui a fait son grand retour et
face à l'épidémie actuelle
l'établissement français du sang tire la
sonnette d'alarmé lance une campagne
d'urgence les besoins en produits
sanguins sont en hausse explications au
micro de haussmann vandeurzen
nous sommes en réserve tout à fait
instable est insuffisante il faut savoir
que l'établissement français du sang on
aime bien avoir quatorze jours de
réserve et qu'actuellement on est en 11
jours 11 jours et demi c'est à dire
globalement on aimerait avoir cent mille
produits en réserve et nous n'en avons
que 73 mid c'est-à-dire 25% un quart de
réserve en moins donc les difficultés et
les appels aux dons